what's the work of being a quote
filmmaker that people don't see people
think okay great you shoot it you've
edited all that but you're really great
at your right beautiful posts are
inferred for tenho open and movie and
also you send around newsletter like
every month or so you do these other
things that are sort of outside the
realm of what people consider you know a
filmmaker but you create an audience
with it yeah what are some of the things
because a lot of people don't want to do
all that yeah then they shouldn't then
they should if someone does not want to
be active in social media or a
newsletter or a blog they should
absolutely they should not do it I know
a guy who's he's a very talented
filmmaker you know he's at a household
name but he's talented and he just hates
that kind of stuff he resists it and he
should at the very very least at the
absolute very least I think people owe
it to their to their support network to
just touch base with them once in a
while even if it's an ugly old email no
but yeah I do it because it all started
because I bought into the notion of
building a fan base and you know social
media blah blah blah all that kinds i
mean i spent hours on my twitter
background you know I mean countless I
would have liked original artwork in
there you know but the good thing is I
ended up really enjoying writing blog
posts I I really enjoy writing guest
posts I enjoy doing things like this
because it's it first and foremost I
just it's a form of creativity I enjoy
it and secondly I like to think I'm
hopefully encouraging others so I do
because I enjoy it the more relational
stuff like my newsletter to friends and
family I do it because like i said i
like to think these people support me
some of them have financially supported
me so i owe it to them to touch base
with them and update them but ultimately
a film maker makes films that's what
they do and
if they don't like all that other stuff
then they need to they need to find
folks that do like that kind of stuff
believe in them I will do it for that
you either pay them or you're part of a
company or something I mean it needs to
be done don't get me wrong you have to
do that as an independent filmmaker all
this stuff like John Reese sherry can
learn they all talk about it's true it's
absolutely true but it's not necessarily
your burden it needs to be done at a
certain point for you and/or your film
but it's not necessarily your burden
because if it's getting in the way from
your filmmaking what is the point
you